the grass is always greener on the other
side of the
fence Envy is always a bad advisor you
get tired of listening and she keeps
talking Envy is a poison drunk by those
who seek to kill another while killing
themselves Envy is a symbol of a loser
who cannot accept the success of
[Music]
another the truest Mark of being born
with great qualities is being born
without
[Music]
Envy the envious man grows lean at the
success of his
[Music]
neighbor Envy always implies conscious
inferiority wherever it resides
[Music]
the chief barrier to happiness is
Envy the envious die not once but as
often as the envied win
Applause Envy is the art of counting the
other fellow's blessings instead of your
own Envy is thin because it bites but
never eats
Envy is a gun with a faulty breach lock
that flares back and burns the
shooter our Envy of others devours us
most of
[Music]
all nothing sharpens sight like
Envy let age not envy draw wrinkles on
thy cheeks
[Music]
Envy follows worth as a shadow follows a
body the louder the dogs bark the less a
lion feels
threatened If roses were not special
weeds would not envy
[Music]
them of the seven deadly sins only Envy
is not
fun few men have the natural strength to
honor a friend's success without
Envy stars do not pull each other down
to be more visible they shine
brighter if a lion turned every time
small dogs barked at it it would be the
laughing stock of the
jungle
Envy eats nothing but its own
heart our Envy always lasts longer than
the happiness of those we
[Music]
Envy the hardest thing for a man is what
is not given to
him a bite from a lion is better than
the look of
envy
Envy doesn't enter an empty
[Music]
house Envy is an eye that sees only what
is
missing Envy is a kind of
[Music]
Praise between imitation and envy
imitation is
better if Envy would burn there would be
no need for
wood a lot of people get so hung up on
what they don't have that they don't
think for a second about what they
really
[Music]
want love looks through a telescope Envy
through a
[Music]
microscope Envy is a disease that can
destroy you if you don't find a way to
get rid of
it
Envy creates silent
enemies Envy is the shadow that follows
good fortune or the dirt that remains
after a successful
life Envy is a dangerous enemy hiding
inside your soul you have to fight it in
order not to lose your own
life Envy comes from people's ignorance
of or lack of belief in their own
gifts Envy is more irreconcilable than
hatred the price of success is to Bear
the criticism of
Envy when men are full of Envy they
disparage everything whether it be good
or bad
blessed is he who has learned to admire
but not envy to follow but not imitate
to praise but not flatter to lead but
not
manipulate Envy lurks at the bottom of
the human heart like a Viper in its
hole Envy motivates some
people
when you criticize someone see if you
are doing it out of envy your criticism
reveals more about yourself than those
you
criticize the poor man is ruined as soon
as he begins to imitate the
rich if malice or Envy were tangible and
had a shape it would be that of a
boomerang
greatness inspires Envy Envy engenders
spite spite spawns
lies Envy is the coward side of hate and
all her ways are Bleak and
desolate Russ consumes iron Envy
consumes
itself do not overrate what you have
received nor Envy others he who envies
others does not obtain Peace of
Mind Envy shoots at others and wounds
itself Envy is the shadow of Pride that
obscures true
identity Envy is the most stupid of
vices there is no advantage to be gain
from
it the jealous bring down the curse they
fear upon their own
heads the jealous are Troublesome to
others but a torment to
themselves Envy is a disease that is
difficult to cure but when that is
important to understand and
overcome
Envy has a slanting eye and a crooked
smile Envy is a measure of
dissatisfaction with one's own life and
the limitations of one's
abilities Envy is a heavy burden that
only someone who has imposed it on
himself
carries Envy is the fear of giving in to
another in
[Music]
something Envy is a sign of a limited
mind that is incapable of perceiving the
success of
[Music]
others Envy is the desire to see others
as poorer or less successful than
[Music]
ourselves Envy is the curse of the
complacent
Envy is like stealing Those who commit
it can never achieve real victory in
life Envy kills love and friendship and
defiles our minds and
[Music]
hearts never trust anyone who wants what
you've got friend or no Envy is an
overwhelming
[Music]
emotion there are tongues that are
governed not by the brain but by Envy
resentment and
[Music]
anger Pride may have Noble magnanimity
vanity never has anything but low
[Music]
Envy people's Envy shows how miserable
they are
a life driven not by love and generosity
but by hatred and envy is not real
life people who are vain in causing Envy
often end up causing
pity the more jealousy people have in
their souls the nastier things are on
their
tongues our Envy is much greater than
other people's
[Music]
money jealousy is worried about its own
good Envy is worried about someone
else's
good envious people will die but Envy
[Music]
never a Critic is a man whose Envy has
prevented him from being a
[Music]
writer
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments